[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau numéro
de paf où nous allons traiter d'une
actualité qui est débordante comme on
dit quand quand on a un vase et qu'on
métro dont on dit ça déborde bale à bane
bezina comment ça va bonjour patrice
très bien quand je vous vois
bah oui moi aussi et vous enseignez
toujours le droit aucun chantage
sciences politiques sciences po apprend
à l'université doit tout à fait donc
tout va bien tout fait mais vous avez
des étudiants qui passent des concours
de plaidoirie exactement cet après midi
le concours veut d'elle des plaidoiries
au conseil constitutionnel donc voilà
aller l'équipe de nice est allé l'équipe
de pas rien alors on est ravis
d'accueillir 10 miles à voir bonjour
bonjour vous êtes étudiant en
informatique informatique et management
saas en école d'ingénieur donc vous
allez devenir ingénieur informaticien si
tout va bien se passe bien donc combien
de temps dans deux ans en troisième
année en 3e année après bac c est très
bien l'alternance est bordé ravi de vous
accueillez alors merci paraît un petit
peu bas parce que là on est surtout
suivre ce qu il ya des gens qui ont la
moyenne de l'âge et donc vous ne paraît
un petit peu des problèmes de la
jeunesse
s'il ya des problèmes tu sais rien jawad
de la jeunesse florence père crée des
bons jours jean-patrice vous êtes vous
êtes avocate au barreau de versailles
absolument mais si c'est dans le droit
du travail toujours aucune journée voilà
un challenge espère que jean baptiste ne
regarde pas l'émission ce quelle
déclaration à patrice je fais une
déclaration également à jean baptiste en
lui disant voilà que tout va bien
distinguer voilà
pour les priver des gens là je me dis
bonjour bonjour et éditeurs et jour j'ai
toujours avec 1 1 et un nouveau livre
d'emmanuel varlet harvard on dit pas non
non non non
no problemo no problemo pas de problèmes
rénaux pour bhl est bon de problème
c'est un très bon roman policier d'un
manuel valls était commandant de police
nationale il a pris sa retraite très
récemment et décrit des traitements me
collard d'où celui là et c'est
l'histoire de deux pauvres types qui les
sites de de saucissonner un auteur à
succès pour lui voler son argent
et puis il ya comme un des deux du des
deux truands qui lui mais ça va quand
même pas si facile que ça et le le chef
du duo lady toujours no problemo nos
problèmes bien évidemment plus ça va
aller plus il ya des billets avec lui lé
problème en plus il ya des problèmes aux
c'est une longue cavale
donc c'est très astucieusement raconter
et puis l'intrigué bien il ya un côté
très social puisque les deux types sont
peut-être moins des pauvres types on
imagine le le type qui se fait
saucissonné est pas aussi facile et
voilà que sarah bassar bas un peu les
cartes et c'est franchement c'est très
très très agréable comme lyon no
problemo emmanuel var là voila voila je
l' ai bien dit c'est que si c'est bien
il alors on arrive dans une semaine ne
peut pas aux élections européennes avec
toujours une campagne un peu morne un
peu triste avec des des sondages qui
nous semblent nous dire que les jeux
sont faits c'est à dire qu'il ya en gros
deux parties qui se détache la liste
rm avec une tête de liste on vous me
direz si vous trouvez bonne pas noises
aux besoins qu'on la trouve
oui est ce que c'est un drôle de foi
tient le mna bull oiseaux qu'on voulait
trouver derrière c'est pour le moins
surprenant voire abracadabrantesque
comme choix enfin c'est en se dotant le
connaît bien les problèmes de l'europe
oui mais le problème c'est être connaît
bien les problématiques de lente mais
personne ne la connaît elle et on peut
pas dire qu'elle ait fait grand chose
pour être connu donc vous aussi un peu
compliqué moi je vois avec les étudiants
que j'ai exclure personne de la connerie
quand j'ai donc c'est assez curieux et
elle imprime pas géré les gens voient
pas qui c'est même hier il y avait un
meeting de la liste renaissance indique
en marche elle n'était même pas là quoi
donc c'est à dire que je veux dire c'est
quand même curieux fabemi d'ailleurs va
y avoir un débat avec les chefs de parti
voilà ça pas elle sait pas et puis et
puis on voit la tête d'emmanuel bakou
surtout qui va
voilà qui va arriver moi je courais est
choquant dans cette élection c'est
l'investissement aussi plein et entier
du président de la république du premier
ministre ministre de l'intérieur dans
une élection qui est pas une élection
nationale il faut quand même le rappeler
je trouve qu'on entend trop parler des
problématiques nationales dans cette
élection palpable alors sans surprise
parce qu'à chaque fois aux européennes
c'est la même chose mais là vraiment au
point d'avoir à recourir au président de
la république c'est vraiment qu'elle
n'arrive pas à faire l'unanimité sur son
nom et je trouve ça un petit peu dommage
d'avoir choisi finalement une candidate
aussi alors là elle a aussi une attitude
qui est pas à mon avis c'est à dire
qu'elle est un petit peu péremptoire
dans sa manière de parler un petit peu
cassantes et du coup elle n'a pas plu au
premier débat qu'elle avait fait bon le
choix d'une européenne est ce qu'elle
est vraiment très européenne d'ailleurs
il paraît qu'elle n'est pas très connu
dans les cénacles européens non plus
donc pas forcément un très bon choix mon
avis mais voilà contre emploi à l'heure
où tout le monde se dit faut être un peu
charismatique
peut-être que voilà mais une sorte de
charme indicible plusieurs années c'est
pas une rumeur c'est pas une bonne
oratrice elle passe pas du tout les
messages n'est pas une bonne idée
motrice non ça c'est clair
mais c'est vrai d'avoir la visage des
manuels macron sur les affiches c'est un
peu sinon je suis aussi un peu choquée
moi je d'autant plus oui non mais
d'autant plus à saluer city sa légitime
tout à mon avis zandé sa légitime le
fait que et marine le pen et la france
insoumise disent il faut voter contre
macron parce que alors que ce n'est pas
le débat alors ça aura des conséquences
sur les si jamais elle si jamais
justement la liste lrm n'est pas en tête
est-ce que ça aura des conséquences sur
la hausse du cac et là mais ça vous
intéresse les européennes nous suivait
ça j'ai regardé un peu et comme elle l'a
dit il parle beaucoup du front national
voilà donc il parle pas assez de
problèmes européens
donc après ouais on s'intéresse un peu
moins aux élections européennes que les
élections nationales ça c'est normal
vous avez éveillé voir la maybach
ça devrait être normal maillet vous
plaît beaucoup d'abstentions et en même
temps quand je dis enfin les jeux sauzon
semble fait c'est vrai que c'est une
mobilisation très forte et du côté
rassemblement national à peu près 80%
des gens qui veulent voter rassemblement
national disent déjà qu'ils vont le
faire et à peu près pareil du côté
république en marche c'est les deux
électorats qui sont assez mobilisés je
pense que la droite aussi peut se
mobiliser parce que mais pour l'instant
elle n'est pas lui mais ce sont des gens
qui se révèle assez tard non mais
maintenant je pense qu'ils vont alors et
avec une bonne campagne plutôt deux
bellamy mais il ya quand même et puis on
va parler peut-être du populisme après
mais il ya quand même un fait
intéressant c'est à dire que si on prend
le rassemblement national
dupont aignan les petites listes sont
philippot est juste plus comment
s'appelle le lot on est à peu près à 30%
30% de droite en eau anti européenne
je simplifie un peu les choses la liste
de la droite traditionnelle
elle est au maximum à 14% ça c'est quand
même un événement non pas tellement
c'est quand même une ombre maire willy
vous avez l'effondrement de la droite
traditionnelle et du parti socialiste de
ceux qui gouvernent depuis 60 ans oui à
mon avis à sa date quand même déjà d'un
petit moment c'est à dire que déjà les
présidentielles et législatives vu que
c'était un véritable une descente aux
enfers pour la droite et pour la gauche
quant aux côtés eurosceptiques c'est là
que je dis pas tellement c'est à dire
que finalement c'est beaucoup plus
audible et l'article de franz olivier
giesbert le monde très bien c'est
beaucoup plus audible aujourd'hui d'être
contredit que d'être pour et ça ça fait
quand même plusieurs années bien beau
juste le missel édito de françois des
visites vers dans le point qui dit comme
on ne peut pas être européens
aujourd'hui mais il dit en même temps
elle les europhobes on en voit partout
les europhiles on les entend peu c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est pas du tout à la
mode final un portrait des europhobes
absolument saisissant quand ils savent
pas les uns sont pas éduqués et s'affale
sa femme ans il mange avec leurs doigts
il n'y a pas fondamentalement tarifs de
la typologie du mais l'électorat
populiste en fait quelque part même là
le dialogue qui est développée de la
part de ces parties là pour essayer de
faire appel aux instances finalement
dépensé la 6e et leurs faux mais tu
devenu une espèce en voie de
prolifération il se reconnaît de loin
à part les exceptions qui confirment la
règle ne parle pas anglais ils voyagent
peu ils zappent la presse il ne connaît
rien à l'économie
en dehors de ce que l'enseignement
public a bien voulu transmettre
autrement dit la vieille soupe à la
pensée unique du monde diplomatique ou
d'alternatives économiques bouffe danses
de toutes les extrémistes après après
son entrée hier sont peut être trop
catastrophiste parce que pas partie de
saison mais beaucoup de gens reprochent
à mâcon d'être trop à droite
il faut pas oublier quand même que le
premier ministre vient de la droite le
maire
darmanin vient de la droite ça manque
pas de gens de droite non plus les
maquereaux donc voilà si l'électeur de
droite il n'est pas non plus orphelin je
veux dire il a quand même
belani d'un côté macro de l'autre un peu
comme si sud entre les deux cantons et
doit donc assez c'est pas non plus une
dilution totale de la france a va être
ça va être une réussite pour la droite
des collectionneurs heureusement puisque
y aura ben-ami forcément qui sera plus
ou moins troisième vie rassemblement
national est en marche qui pour la
position européenne est plutôt situé à
droite donc en effet ça risque d'être un
résultat très à droite très à droite oui
mais offre quand même il faut drum en 2d
partis traditionnels de confirmation
vous avez affirmé déjà voter ou pas
fonction présidentielle résidentiel et
est ce que je sais pas vous avez vous
avez l'impression qu'on avait quelque
chose de nouveau qui se passait dans le
paysage politique où est-ce que vous
découvriez sa maman c'était la première
et
en fait c'est surtout pour les résultats
qui a eu quelque chose de nouveau vu que
on s'était habitué pc à gauche avec le
parti socialiste ou bien l'europe donc
là avec macro on était tous un peu
surpris ou bien soit c'était quelque
chose de nouveau
surtout pour les résultats macro et sur
les élections européennes vous allez
voter ou pas je vous montre bien sûr je
vais voter droit de voter dans quoi je
souhaitais d'accord oui donc et 30% de
d'anti-européen ça me paraît pas énorme
ça me parait tristement classique depuis
quelques temps on évolue un petit peu
vers cette querelle contre l'europe on
n'arrive plus vraiment je trouve que
d'ailleurs ces élections ont encore faim
cette campagne a encore empiré les
choses c'est à dire qu'on n'arrive pas à
avoir des véritables arguments europhile
qu'ils soient convaincants c'est à dire
que les postures des européens
convaincus sont trop évidentes ou en
tout cas ramenant ça et je crois que
c'est ce qui a créé le break 6 c'est à
dire que finalement on ne peut pas
sortir de l'europe c'est un acquis c'est
mieux comme ça mais on n'arrive pas à le
démontrer au point que finalement les
peuples ont envie d'être contestataires
et d'avoir des résultats
cette campagne elle aurait pu aider
justement à l'europe à se renouveler
faut savoir que la commission européenne
elle avait proposé 4 types d'europe pour
ces élections
l'europe en moins l'europe en plus
l'europe à plusieurs l'urp aaa avec un
binôme au pas et ça c'était censé être
le grand argument de ces européennes je
pense qu'en france on ne l'a même pas
évoquer donc on ne connaît même pas les
partis européens dans lesquels les
partis vont s'intégrer il faut savoir
qu'on est en train de vivre les arts
être est ce que c'est ça qui est
important aussi c'est il ya le il ya le
vote après européen avec l autre avec
des grands partis comme le ppe qui est
la droite mais la droite avec des gens
comme urban enfin exactement comme si
facile vont rester dans le pp ou pas je
crois que si les calculs de macron
d'ailleurs tout à fait de dire il ya
peut-être un
sa tournée de gens du ppe qui vont en
sortir pour ne pas être allié avec les
boulistes tout à fait et je pense qu'on
raisonne avec nos mécanismes français de
scrutin majoritaire c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'il va y avoir un gagnant
mais il faut rappeler que les élections
européennes sont des élections qui
seront à la proportionnelle donc c'est
vos résultats qui commande le nombre de
sièges que vous allez avoir donc un
troisième n'est pas un perdant dans une
élection proportionnelle bien au
contraire il va être important et donc
ça veut dire que on va ramener tout ça
au niveau de l'europe en plus pour
savoir combien de sièges il y aura pour
une liste plutôt à gauche plutôt à
droite et plutôt ça c'est ce que vous
dites est bien évidemment totalement
exact mais c'est probablement ce qui
fait peur aussi à beaucoup de gens se
faire qu on a un peu l'impression d'une
dilution de son vote qu'on dit ok on va
vous et et puis après où ça va comme moi
comment ça va se passer je ne sais pas
et je pense que c'est une des craintes
que les gens ont dans tous les pays
européens vis à vis de l'europe se dire
que le rap est pas vécu comme quelque
chose d'absolument extraordinaire est
vécu comme la dilution de la nation
faire que les gens on peut avoir envie
d'être français et européens et là on a
toujours l'impression qu'avec les partis
européens
c'est ridicule d'être français il faut
être européen maintenant on peut être
français européens allemands et
européens et que des inondations restent
quand même quelque chose d'important et
de discours assez entendu je pense que
c'est une erreur de la campagne si
finalement la campagne se faisait
vraiment sur les parti-pris européens et
sur ce qui va être votée au parlement
européen au moins on aurait le sentiment
de voter pour un but alors que la
semoule dans l'esprit c'était justement
une des raisons pour lesquelles la
compagne est un peu morne c'est à dire
que en effet entre freud et marine le
pen était pour l'heure sortait de l'euro
a cédé avant c'était une position assez
claire anti-européenne là elle dit on va
changer l'europe de l'intérieur ce qui
est totalement impossible puisque au
maximum les députés populiste entre
guillemets seront 170 ses dires une très
faible minorité au parlement européen
doc et ils n'auront aucun poids pour
changer d'europe de la taille et de la
même façon les les pro européens
la liste aura des sens ils sont assez
modérés dans leurs oraux fini si je peux
lire il faut remercier les anglais parce
qu'en fait tout ça c'est grâce aux
briques site faire que nommé avant le
break city avait encore plein de partie
des défauts quitter l'europe etc et puis
là on voit quand même le seul pays qui
décident d'eux qu'ils se rendent au
coriace minots comment changer la donne
tout le monde s'est dit bah oui on ne
peut pas on va pas non plus faire
n'importe quoi il exerça recentrer le
débat social c'est plutôt bien après
qu'on se perde un peu dans les méandres
de la 2de du parlement effectivement
quelle personne ne comprend trop où vont
aller véritablement savoir enfin c'est
vrai que là si on vote combattront après
à quoi ça va servir vraiment ou si on
vote pour bellamy ou si on veut être
pour pour polymusclés peut-être une ou
deux personnes qui ont été pour hamon je
ne sais pas si ces deux personnes vont
être un peu oui perdait 2,34 liste quand
même c'est incroyable en a l'air
absolument ridicule aux yeux de la
commission d'ailleurs parce que je pense
que en europe on doit être à peu près
les seuls à avoir autant de candidats
d'autant de couleur pour si peu de
choses puisque je suis d'accord avec toi
finalement la dilution sera réel donc
vous avez lu beaucoup vont avoir aucun
des nues quand à la question de
l'argument européen
oui voilà bon jeu j'ai peur que cette
campagne finalement
soit un groupe chiite c'est à dire que
l'on parle des enjeux nationaux sans
finalement pouvoir les réaliser et on ne
retrouvera pas ce résultat dans les
élections elles-mêmes donc avec avec une
incapacité d'alliance à gauche quand
même qui quand même ça se discute un
là-bas au parlement européen puisque
finalement les parties se recompose un
petit peu d'eux-mêmes et donc je m'en
vais là il ya les sociétés d'ici à bout
oui il ya évidemment les insoumis ya le
parti communiste un qui est excellent il
est très très bien très clair en tout
cas ce qui est bien monsieur je suis pas
d'accord avec vous les 34 liste c'est
plutôt bien parce que ça raccourci le
temps de parole de chaque liste et non
un mais je suis sérieux et et tous les
soirs je regarde juste rabbani khar
yalla la campagne sur la sur france 2
après le journal télévisé et du coup les
interventions sont tous sont hyper
courte alors qu'avant de parler pendant
dix minutes où vous endormez qui ils
sont et d'aller très très vite
et du coup ça donne quand même une prime
aux gens intelligents et au parti digne
de ce nom
et du coup il ya quand même quelques
crétins on va pas les nommer par par
charité
enfin il ya des listes même on se dit
mettant les types même inconcevable
qu'ils aient tous et le chemin de la
préfecture pour déposer la liste enfin
on a dû les aider tellement ils sont
curieux psychologiquement bon eh bien
cela ils s'expriment ils disent en gros
vraiment il n'ya pas d'autres mots ils
disent des conneries mais très vite
après est un parti normal qu'ils soient
de gauche ou droite où la hausse des
barèmes heureusement il ya encore des
gens intelligents en france donc c'est
pas mal 34 liste ça permet de voir quand
même qu'à des listes crime digne de ce
nom et puis d'autres c'est des clowns
totalement l inverse de cet argument
dans le sens où pour moi ça dit lui
complètement encore plus la campagne
c'est à dire que plus on fragmente et
plus on va vers l'essentiel plus on
caricature à mon sens et donc du coup sa
force tous les partis à être dans la
caricature d'eux-mêmes
on a absolument jamais eu une trace des
propositions européennes qui ont été
faites par aucun des candidats que ce
soit l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite
la droite l'a donc
ces mini clip à mon avis si on s'en
passe on peut même carrément faire sans
savoir vraiment de véritable débat sur
le dos peut oublier vue bellamy ça dure
et très peu de temps il fait son petit
son petit clip comme vous dites devant
le parvis de notre dame
je veux dire c'est clair et net je boite
clip on voit ce qu'il veut dire ça mais
le net c'est raté à la droite trocadéro
comme une autre ça c'était bien c'est
clair ça oblige et de concision voit
tout de suite ça m'oblige à être aussi
un peu caricatural est devant une église
ça veut pas ça donne les racines
chrétiennes de l'europe et finalement on
n'a pas le reste de son programme qui
traite la totalité des français parmi
lesquels via des vis des jaunes il faut
forcément être un peu caricatural pour
être entendu donc je ne faut pas avoir
non plus un champ il faut pas avoir un
champ lexical tromper tendu quoi donc on
est obligé d'aller à avoir conclu au
fait par exemple pour vous avez des
convictions personnelles mais est-ce que
la campagne peut influer votre vote ce
que vous regardez les débats les lever
les la campagne officielle
moi je regarde un peu dans le français
comme il agit mais
justement je voulais dire que les temps
de parole ne sont pas équitables
justement par rapport à ça et ils nous
montrent que les personnes qui sont on
va dire au top de la des sondages comme
comme le parti en marche et le parti
réseau national et comme ladji je pense
était mélenchon il a dit que c'est plus
devenu un duel un duo rien qu'un comme
une élection avec 34 liste du qui met en
avant avec les temps de parole plus
élevé donc ça ça ça rentre dans nos
têtes que il met en avant que donc c'est
pas un peu compliqué je pense que de
faire notre choix de ce que vous dites
que temps de parole il est
rigoureusement le même à la ville mais
très peu sur la campagne officielle où
il est pareil est en tout cas pour en
tout cas pour le font les grosses listes
qui passe tout ou même heure etc ou
abriel et des balles hautes
autant de deux secondes et deux minutes
de parole que lorsque la cedh égalité
qui est vrai qu'il va dominer par
rapport aux clips justement que les
temps parole n'était pas afin d'étendre
clip n'était pas n'était pas équitable
je crois que justement le csa est passé
à une règle de l'équité un petit peu
plus étendue que la règle de l'égalité
et donc du coup aujourd'hui on n'est
plus obligé de donner la minute et la
seconde près s'il fallait faire parler
tous les eaux des toilettes de 36 et on
est passé aujourd'hui à cette règle de
l'équité qui a faussé mérité ses
errements et vous compliquez piéplu qui
est bouclé un peu bête
et puis elle est un peu injuste dans le
sang sont en fait plus vous êtes connu
plus vous avez de temps parole et moi
vous êtes reconnu le composant n'aviez
donc c'est une personne qui fait pas
énormément de recherches qui regarde
juste la télé bien il aura juste ce que
les médias veulent le convoi mais alors
c'est ce que vous avez raison c'est vrai
sur vous sur l'organisation des débats
pas c'est compliqué de faire des débats
avec 34 personnes non alors il ya un qui
protestent parce qu'ils disent ils le
débat avec les grands et puis le débat
notamment dupontel et n'y en ait pas
très content d'être avec les petits mais
bon comment faire c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué quelques semaines je
souhaitais rendu compte que c'était une
véritable cacophonie donc c'est très
difficile d'être à la fois audible et
équitable voir égal et on avait beaucoup
reproché aux campagnes officielles
auparavant d'être très factice puisque
finalement donnant autant de temps de
parole à chasse et pêche et tradition qu
aux partis de gouvernement donc ouest où
est le bon équilibre j'ai tendance à
penser que l'équité a quand même ses
mérites dans le sens où on n'est pas
obligé d'entendre trop de temps de
parole à l'un ou à l'autre et qu'on
essaye de respecter alors aujourd'hui la
règle est encore plus complexe puisque
le csa a demandé une équité et une
proportionnalité en soit encore plus
difficile à calculer mais ce qui permet
quand même d'avoir normalement un petit
équilibre pour les petites formations
donc où est la justice ça se discute
c'est de savoir où on met le curseur est
hélas c'est compliqué l'avenir je viens
la question de la droite au fond parce
que certains disent finalement que la
droite traditionnelle a raté un peu le
coche on ne savions pas avec le
populisme avec la avec le rassemblement
national
bon enfin cesser les gens du front
national qui devinrent srx séries alors
pour le coup il pouvait avoir une liste
très très en avance
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
peut-être intérêt à faire croire et c
est absolument rien de commun entre la
droite et fondé le rassemblement
national après la donc s'élever à
dompter mais c'est lui c'est une thèse
qu'on entend enfin arriver oui oui mais
au fait c'est une thèse que je suis très
futés que ce trouve grotesque le lien
des droits ça n'a rien à voir donc voilà
je veux dire tu me rien à voir entre gpa
raffarin entre bellamy et enfin soutien
non non mais justement ce but mais il
était quand même il reste il reste de
droite je veux dire qu'ils fassent
alliance pour le problème des chevalets
de la liste évoquée angola mais se dire
franchement ce que je ne les auvergnats
bellamy et des ouvertures de laurent
votive vera parleurs dans les programmes
quand on est encadré chose appliquer des
choses un peu commune mais en vain je
suis complètement d'accord on peut pas
laisser un désert entre en marche et le
rassemblement national sous peine d'être
vraiment pour le coup caricatural et de
montrer qu'on a plus aucun discours
politiques libérales progressistes de
droite et je crois que vraiment pour le
coup la liste bellamy mois pour moi a
réussi son pari dans le sens où il ya
une cohésion qui s'est créée autour d'un
complètement inattendu on a les barons
du parti qui ont siégé avec lui lors de
son dernier congrès on a une droite qui
s'est un peu réunis à mon avis donc je
pense que vraiment le job a été remplie
après quant au poids dans l'électorat
malheureusement bon on part de très loin
quand même avec la sphère fillon avec
cette décomposition de la droite à la
suite de l'élection présidentielle donc
il y avait quand même j'ai envie de dire
la nappe l'annapurna remonter donc
structuré je trouve qu'ils ont quand
même bien sûr les soi-disant point
commun je veux dire je le rappellerai le
mot de fabuleuses côté des premiers
ministres qui disait si jean marie le
pen dit que si elle est bleue et que le
ciel est bleu je vais pas dire que si
elle est noire bon c'était voilà 08
donne de mauvaises réponses à de relater
ce qui ont valu mauvaises réponses à de
vraies questions aussi pensent donc de
temps en temps le rassemblement national
perd une position commune lui-même avec
en mars mais avec beaucoup de partis ce
que de temps en temps quand même s'ils
sont pas totalement le bouton mise et
enfin le temps on peut dire bah oui
c'est la côte mot idiot
alors si c'est vrai que c'est très
facile d'aider que bellamy ou vos
clientèle
enchaîne sur les racines chrétiennes de
la france arrête tout de suite il ya le
ban et l'arrière ban de la gauche tous
qu'elle est en train de dire ça y est
ces délais les fascistes reviennent bah
non non je veux dire on peut aimer
trouvé des racines chrétiennes à la
france et à l'europe sans être pour
autant un facho enfin je pense en tout
cas c'est vrai que je suis d'accord avec
vous il ya certains points de
convergence qui sont par exemple sur la
question de la renégociation des traités
pour l'intégration des dépenses dans les
critères de convergence ou pas il ya
certains points communs mais en effet on
peut même en trouver entre autres font
sur sa vie à bellamy et glucksmann alors
à ce moment là donc des points communs
et des points de divergence urnes et
même parfois entre le parti de mélanger
et françois-xavier bellamy apprécier
encore lebeaupin il ya beaucoup dans
thor travaillait beaucoup d'accords il
essaie peut-être de coalition il ya
beaucoup voilà selon les problèmes les
soldes et les dossiers total il ya
tellement de points communs qu'il ya
même un type du la france insoumise
cadavres qui vient de rejoindre et ses
cotations mais n'ont pas qu'un quota rac
qui était qui été élu conseiller
régional d'auvergne rhône alpes qui
était chez mélenchon qui soutient la
liste rassemblement national mais ça
c'est un vrai alors pour le coup c'est
un vrai débat sur le positionnement de
ce qu'est la france atomise est ce que
c'est un parti de gauche mais dans ce
cas là il devrait faire alliance avec
des sorties de vous je ne le font pas il
ya vingt ministres communistes ou voudra
pas dire mené par ian brossât
il ya il faut pas dire cette partie ces
listes pourquoi ils soutiennent pas plus
que man est faillible et en même temps
il ne se rapproche pas du rassemblement
national c'est dire qu'il ne ils ne
jouent pas leur fibre populiste et
est-ce que ça n'explique pas ce nom fois
entre est-ce qu'on est de gauche ou
est-ce qu'on est populiste le fait que
finalement le bleu les insoumis sont un
chiffre aujourd'hui enfin dans les airs
dans les sondages moi je trouve que les
économies ont perdu leurs idées
il joue en fait c'est ça qui leur a
coûté la vie il y avait eu une petite
envolée avant justement mais le
peut-être dans le fait de l'avoir pris
trop opaque heures en considérant que du
coup il allait étudier et bien
finalement il s'est complètement
décrédibilisé et je pense que c'est la
figure de jean luc mélenchon qui
finalement a desservi son mouvement
quant au positionnement
c'est une gauche qui n'est pas
totalement similaire avec ce qu'on avait
entendu jusqu'à lors du parti communiste
donc c'est vrai que c'est un extrême
gauche un peu particulier - quant à la
fibre populiste même si c'est vrai que
la carte est pas complètement joué j'ai
quand même tendance à penser qu'elle est
réelle et qu'on retrouve un petit peu
avec lui les aspirations podemos en
espagne c'est à dire un mouvement qui
n'a pas véritablement de coloration et
qui est censé partir de la base et qui
est un mouvement vraiment pour le peuple
par le peuple
après finalement est-ce que ça a
vraiment de la consistance je crois que
ce qu'on se rend compte avec ces
élections c'est que plus on se perd
entre différentes listes entre coupé
comme ça 33 non plus chacun du mal à
défendre son identité je crois que c'est
un petit peu le problème des insoumis
c'est que dans cette fragmentation du
discours ils ont ils ont du mal à tenir
tête à des partis aussi proches que
amont que les socialistes que voire même
le rassemblement national de l'autre
côté tout le monde paraît un peu commun
donc est ce que ça veut dire que c'est
la mort d ensemble je suis pas sûr est
ce que cette initiative la de cet élu
enfin elle est très isolé ou est-ce que
pour ce qu'il peut y avoir un jour une
situation à l'italienne auront enfin
entre alliance entre la gauche radicale
et le la droite populiste gauche droite
populiste que je pense surtout c'est
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment d espace pour
deux partis extrémistes
enfin disons que voilà après c'est un
peu un balancement je veux dire là le
rassemblement national semble monter
très fort et ça fait baisser la france a
soumis et peut-être que à la prochaine
élection ça serait équilibré dans
l'autre sens on l'a vu historiquement
c'est toujours un peu ça il n'y a pas la
place pour deux partis extrémistes et à
15%
donc c'est un peu les mêmes gens qui
sont là parce que peut-être aussi que
nous on enfin le on a toujours tendance
dans les débats à sortir des grands
thèmes de débats qui concernent en fait
des gens qu'on pas trop de soucis que
quelques voix aider des gens qui ont des
soucis beaucoup plus terre-à-terre et
qui et pour qui virent l'islamisation
les racines chrétiennes de la france et
c'est pas vraiment leurs soucis
quotidiens et voilà donc ces gens là et
qui se retrouvent pas un moment chez
mélenchon par un bon front national je
veux dire ça n'en fait pas ni des ça
c'est qu'il ya des bons et des points de
convergence j'avais même électorat que
les deux disent ce soit mélenchon marine
le pen c'est contre macro donc cet
insoumis
son argument pour dire je pense
mélenchon a dit il faut battre macron je
pense à battre macron c'est le front
d'un face et le rassemblement national
donc je rejoins le rassemblement
national dont j'obéis à mélenchon mais
justement le le le le vieux clivage
enfin politique droite gauche au fait
qui a présidé en france pendant de
nombreuses années qu'ils ont peut-être
en train de s'estomper ou d'autres
formes c'est quelque chose qui est
encore important pour au pot pour vous
pourrez déjà le droit de cochon il est
en train de lui en train de mourir vous
voyez leur part du centre allait se
passer quelque chose mais nous situe par
exemple politique bon enfin vous oui
même même s'il meurt je pense qu'il est
toujours toujours d'actualité ont
toujours on se réfère lui les droits
depuis les trous
l'huile et d'une puissante et c'est ce
côté là qui nous fait entre guillemets
choisir la personne si la personne vient
de gauche on va être si on a une
personne ne bougera plus et adaptable
dessus contrat - s'il est de droite
alors que s'il ya passé par kilo on peut
être un peu perdu mais d une lecture
assez simple vont devoir là c'est avant
de rentrer dans le partant dans son
intention programme on voit directement
la face à de la façade c'est ce droite
qu'au jeu et c'est ça qui me suis un peu
et nous donne une un aspect de la
personne et vous comprendrez qu'il des
gens par exemple l'eau france insoumise
qui passe au gros rassemblement national
ça vous choque
ous à l'inversé c'est choquant sachant
que ils ont toujours été entre
guillemets en conflits passés de l'autre
côté c'est assez surprenant mais c'est
arrivé en italien je suis arrivé en
italie oui ben ainslie une alliance
entre rôle l'extrême gauche et sa droite
par wes halliwell d'acorn cette vie des
personnes qui fait le passage entre d'un
côté à l'autre c'est ça le studio et ce
qui est du match c'était c'était la
gauche et à droite jean fort tard et un
petit peu moins ahurissant pour une
élection européenne dans le sens où du
coup les deux extrêmes se rejoignent en
un espèce de cfa
puis à partir du moment où ils sont
absolument contre le système européen
tel qu'il existe au moins il ya des
points de convergence qui sont un petit
peu plus évident sachant que c'est
peut-être encore plus facile d'être à
l'extrême droite qu'est l'extrême gauche
dans ces énoncés campagne là alors
justement le populisme les elop ce
qu'ils faisaient là dessus ces pays vide
sous le populisme avec la hongrie
l'autriche l'italie la pologne le point
dit l'homme fort de l'europe c'est
salvini on a l'impression et si on
regarde les les intentions de vote
en angleterre les bras exit heures et il
divo dans le dr leleu le passé de
paréage attaqué quelques créer un
nouveau parti et à plus de 30% des
intentions de vote soit après un petit
unis aussi non mais tout le monde est
apte regardez comme c'est difficile de
sortir de leur robe en tweed les anglais
mais quand on regarde les intentions de
vote les débris dieter fallait pour la
sortie sont assez majoritaire ce qui est
logique quand même c'est à dire qu'on
est en train de faire voter un état qui
est sur le départ donc
après autant voter pour les députés qui
vont aider à le faire mais vite ses
propres non je pense que c'est une
logique
l'erreur était peut-être de ne pas
régler ce bras exit avant les élections
européennes l'ouverture c'est la faute
de l'angleterre
aujourd'hui elle est obligée d'amener
des élus dans un parlement qu'elle a
autant décrié donc autant que ces
parlementaires soit pour la sortie ça me
parait jeunes en fait ils sont pour le
blocage des commissions de ses attaches
de l'europe ils sont bloqués devant il
ya confrères tire surtout il serait
temps moi ce qui me gêne un petit peu
dans tout ce que vous dites est ce que
ce que la presse 10 et dès que le un
peuple vote d'une façon qui n'est pas la
façon qui plaît aux élites c'est pas
très démocratique ont débarrassé des
coups ils votent c'est populiste ils ont
voté très mal s'il met deux des blessés
il ya un déni de la démocratie pas dire
ça à 70 c'est pas bien c'est les
populistes à c'est une catastrophe etc
on a dit la même chose aux états unis où
on traite tous les américains de cons
parce qu'ils ont voté pour toi et qui
vont revoter pour lui
comme la fleur au fusil mais à chaque
fois il ya un mépris de leurs boys ils
vous n'êtes pas comme nous on aurait dû
voter comme on leur a dit de voter on
dirait ce n'était pas le bon candidat
en italie c'est pas comme ça oui c'est
quoi ça sert en angleterre c'est pas
comme ça faut arrêter de critiquer ou
allant des non chrétiens au fer rouge
les gens qui ont volé les contours 10 et
ce n'est pas une critique ça d'accord
mais quand vous dites ou essais des
populistes ont pris le pouvoir donc le
peuple le peuple a le pouvoir c'est la
démocratie
alors après on peut trouver que la
démocratie ça quand bien même on peut
bien dire les zones urbaines denses
comme un exemple de démocratie
arrêtez de dire que l'ouverture
on n'arrête pas dire si cela démocratie
mais ce qu'on apprécie donne quelque
chose rare mais ça c'est pas bien parce
qu'au lieu des 62
c'est le côté absurde de la situation
mais c'est de dire si vous voyez des
gens très d'accord mais bon là on leur a
demandé leur avis sur le vote
on leur a pas dit et ce qu'il faut voter
ou pas poser le débat c'est à dire que
finalement ton argument est le socle du
populisme c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où on oppose les élites au peuple
en oubliant que c'est le peuple qui a
élu les élites
à mon avis c'est là qu'on tombe dans la
démagogie et c'est ça qu'on reproche au
discours populiste faut faire attention
d'ailleurs à pas confondre les partis
politiques populistes qui pour le coup
n'existe plus c'était vraiment le
boulangisme s'était même des choses qui
étaient un petit peu moins fasciste
comme tu dis qu'à l'heure actuelle que
le discours populiste et le discours
populiste c'est de la démagogie propres
j'aime beaucoup maurice duverger qui
disait le populisme finalement c'est la
démocratie sans son peuple et moi je
crois que c'est vraiment ça qu'on est en
train de vivre aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que ce sont des partis qui prétendent
redonner le pouvoir au peuple mais qui
finalement tape sur les élites qui elles
mêmes ont été élus en essayant de donner
un discours favorable à l'air du temps
sans même se préoccuper des moyens
qu'ils auront pour défendre ces
politiques et je crois que c'est
totalement le cas de donald trump qui a
séduit sur un discours america first et
voilà un discours finalement
nationaliste et qui est en train de
creuser le déficit extérieur quand il va
partir alors espérons que ce soit dans
huit ans pour qu'ils aient le temps de
remonter la marque avant parce que sinon
il va donner une bébé avec l'eau du bain
et ça va être une cata
pour celui qui va lui succéder je pense
la même chose de matteo salvini il reste
dans l'europe pour torpiller l'europe
il a gardé un budget mais dans les faits
au fond le pays pour lui comme pour la
dette grecque
et c'est finalement lui qui déséquilibre
le système donc moi je crois que c'est
parti populiste la seule chose qui les
distingue des parties proprement
démocratique c'est pas cette opposition
avec les mythes c'est qu'ils promettent
aux peuples des choses plus séduisante
que finalement ils n'auront qu'un moyen
de télimélé totalement d'accord je dis
juste qu'on ne peut pas mépriser les
gens qui votent et qui exprime une idée
qu après des partis politiques ne soient
pas capables ou de contrer le discours
des partis populistes c'est ça le drame
moi j'ai tout à fait d'accord que
quelqu'un aille voter et vote en
écoutant des arguments s'il n'y a pas
d'autres arguments d'arguments plus fort
on peut pas lui reprocher au moins ils
votent et s'exprime en ce qui me
concerne vraiment très personnellement
c'est ni du mépris mais c'est vraiment
de la désolation c'est à dire que je
pense comme je vois que nous n'arrivons
pas à donner un discours alternatif et
un discours clair en face de ce
populisme parce que il emprunte un
langage beaucoup plus familier un
langage qui fait appel aux instincts
même les populations en leur parlant du
droit national du droit au travail des
inégalités ou flattant les nationalismes
et donc du coup on revient aux instincts
les plus bas à mon avis et c'est en ça
que je suis absolument d'accord et franz
olivier giesbert c'est que c'est même
plus un discours qui s'adresse aux
intellect matteo salvini avait dit je ne
veux pas faire appel à votre
intelligence je veux faire appel à votre
coeur qu'est ce que ça veut dire dans
une élection ça veut simplement dire
qu'on est en train de rabaisser discours
et moi c'est vraiment ça qui est sur les
rails mais les passionne et encore dans
cette campagne
la liste renaissance à mon avis n'a pas
apporté de véritables arguments du jour
outre cela et je trouve que dans
l'europe et même au niveau mondial on
n'arrive pas à se positionner contre ces
populistes donc on leur laisse un
boulevard qui est un peu un échec de
macron parce que c'était son cheval de
bataille lors sachant qu'il avait été
qu'elle arrivait de police d'ailleurs au
départ quand il a été membre
il n'a pas réussi sont pas si faciles
puisque mme merkel a dit qu'elle avait
des divergences conflit avec lui la
nation russe qui se comprend parce que
elle elle a une gestion intérieur à
régler fola c'est une coalition elle
fait pas ce qu'elle veut elle a raison
de dire d'ailleurs j'ai pas le même
pouvoir exact le président de la
république français elle n'a pas le même
pouvoir n a pas du tout le même système
constitutionnel et je pense que c'est
quand même beaucoup plus équilibrée en
allemagne où finalement on peut faire
des gosses us vendôme on peut faire
voter moins de promesses qu'un président
français qui finalement quand ils
s'engagent s'engage seul et emmène à peu
changé ne peut changer
il viendra totalement conscience parce
que sa politique de mi-mandat de
maquereaux et comme elle n'est pas la
même et c'est une politique
électoraliste iphone où sortez-vous fois
est ce qu on entend beaucoup discours
nationaliste voilà retour à la nation
serait mieux si on était contre nous
essayons fermer nos frontières
vous vous sentez français européens
les deux français européens en premier
en premier français ensuite bien sûr
européen mais j'ai vu benoît hamon qui a
dit que s'il voulait avoir un une
en europe c'est à dire que un état
européen et européennes c'est une bonne
idée mais je pense que c'est compliqué
puisque chaque chaque pays a sa
politique différente donc on peut pas
avoir tous une même policier qu'on est
d'abord notre pays et donc d'abord
français pour nous ensuite européen on
peut pas avoir on peut pas être d'abord
européens en dessous de français à
savoir d'abord suivre les règles de
payer ensuite européens il pourrait y
avoir des convergences
voilà c'est pourtant vers chaque pays en
politique j'ai fait un legs attention
européenne existe depuis 92 ouvriers
circuler d'un pays à l'autre dans
l'europe s'est installée c'est là aussi
c'est un peu la nature et 10 moscou
pourrait mais ça poserait forcément des
problèmes et on pourrait penser par
exemple à des référendum tout le monde
votre et en même temps et de la majorité
sera la majorité européenne serre on n'y
est pas encore non mais pourquoi pas
[Musique]
c'est pas pour demain jusqu'à quel point
d'ailleurs le suffrage universel est
vraiment intéressant pour les élections
européennes alors je suis toujours pour
que le peuple vote je te rassure sur ce
point néanmoins toujours autant
d'abstention des discours toujours aussi
caricaturaux aussi nationaux pourquoi
ces élections européennes ne sont
finalement pas organisé par l'union
elle-même
il y avait un système avant 76 qui à mon
avis avait aussi ses avantages qui
consistait à envoyer nous représentants
parlementaires français au parlement
européen
alors c'est un système de représentation
certes indirecte mais au moins est ce
que cette question de la dilution et
n'était pas un peu moins actuelle quand
on fait voter tout le monde alors que
personne ne s'y intéresse aux dragons t
pour les partis existent en europe n est
pas fort des listes dès qu'on reproche à
l'europe un déficit de démocratie si si
en plus on lève une élection au suffrage
universel des listes transnationales
ça ce serait bien oui
cela dit non mais il ya des candidats
par exemple sur la liste sur les listes
renaissance il ya un italien iard
il ya des il ya quelques mois et lue sur
la liste française
en panne d'idées déjà on connaît pas
vraiment les députés européens
c'est vrai ça permettrait aussi
intéressé de connaître les gens mais de
toute façon très honnêtement on connaît
personne parce que bien évidemment sur
les 33 10 en tout il ya près de 4000
candidats du coup enfin bon mais je
défie quiconque de me citer plus loin
que le numéro 3 mais même dans les mêmes
des trois listes est plus connue fait du
bien c'est impossible on arrive à peine
à 3 c donc on peut mettre n'importe qui
après gérance ne sera pas ce qui est
assez désespérant peut-être c'est en
effet cette soeur de frilosité des
candidats a parlé d'europe alors que
celui qui n'avait plus parlé il ya
quelques années dans ce n'était pas le
dernier des élections européennes je
pense que celles d'avant c'était cohn
bendit qui menait la liste verte qui
avait parlé d'europe et qui avait fait
19 % parce qu'elle est ce un score
incroyable qu'on pende et une liste
verte en parlant d'europe
bien sûr donc c'est peut-être un exemple
qui doit qu'il aurait fallu essuyer est
ce que l'idée vous faites des études
vous allez être ingénieur informaticien
à ce que vous avez l'impression de faire
partie d'une élite
non non non je pense que l'élite c'est
d'abord ceux qui sont dans les grandes
écoles dans une école c'est moi je suis
dans une université en fait non je suis
pas partie d'une élite en même temps
vous avez que le voilà je regarde les
statistiques des beaucoup moins de le
chômage on parle beaucoup de chômage des
jeunes qui est très fort mais qui est
très forte chez les jeunes qui n'ont pas
fait d'études qui est beaucoup moins
beaucoup plus flou c'est un cd c'est ce
qui vous fait notamment du ca c mais
déjà qu'est ce que l'élite pour vous ne
vous demandez pas ce que j'en entends on
peut en parler de populisme des discours
anti élitiste et il ya cette ce projet
de suppression notamment de l'énorme à
écouter suppression de l'ena ouais c'est
vrai que c'est cette école dirigée mal à
bois dur d qui n'est pas énarque c'était
une école de l'élite ajustements mais on
la surprend la suppression lassus près
en la supprimant c'est quoi le s qui va
en créer une nouvelle ou bien ils font
j'ai pas vu le problème c'est qu'au fond
il sera alors pour l'instant il ya une
mission qui est confiée à monsieur qui
rit qui était l ancien président de la
ligue de football professionnel mais qui
était marqué lui-même avec travail de
longue haleine très bien qui est avocat
au conseil d'état qui est qui va faire
rapport sur la suppression des bas c'est
vrai que avant l'ena il y avait des
concours différents voyez-vous les
affaires étrangères il y avait les
filles ont cv ça
lina mène à beaucoup de choses après le
procès qu'on fait à l'ena sur l'énarchie
c'était nicolas sarkozy notamment qui
avaient beaucoup brocardé cette grande
école je pas sûr qu'il soit complètement
fondées parce que l'ena comme le nm on
réussit quand même à faire une belle
mutation vers les classes moyennes vers
la province on aura beaucoup reproché à
une forme d'élitisme alors que je crois
que ce sont des écoles qui finalement
sont même un peu à tout les énarques qui
restent dans les autres administrations
sont puisqu'on voit toujours c'est
toujours de la politique
c'est en effet ce sont les abriter mais
oui en plus ce sont les gars de la promo
général était dans la botte mais il y en
a la plupart qui partent ensuite
pantoufler dans le privé alors je pense
que justement c'est là qu'est reste dans
l'administration et des hauts
fonctionnaires croient que ce que veut
faire
emmanuel macron et je termine très
rapidement c'est justement de proposer
une école qui soit directement une école
de la fonction publique de base pour
amener à ce que ce soit les
fonctionnaires qui deviennent haut
fonctionnaire donc gérer lors qu'on me
reproche encore plus d'élitisme une
prime aux gros concours interne
je crois que c'est ce qui est prévu je
trouve que ce qu'on peut reprocher à
l'ena c'est ce n'est pas la qualité de
la formation qui est à l'évidence
extrêmement brillante probablement
extraordinaire et un niveau rarement
égalé même donc même dans d'autres pays
ce qui est un peu tragique c'est
probablement le cheminement d'un type
qui fait l'ena et qu'il ne voulait verra
jamais autre chose que la fonction
publique les grands corps d'état etc et
qui après quand ils arriveront aux
responsabilités pour parler comme au
long il est temps
coupé du monde qui ne sait même pas ce
que c'est que il a jamais géré ne serait
ce que 1 rayons d'épicerie ne sais même
pas ce que c'est que d'être un endroit
où on voit par exemple un type comme
françois hollande était arrivé président
de la république sans jamais avoir mis
les pieds donc autre chose que la
fonction il a été élu non il a été ce
qu'il a été il aurait fait beaucoup de
fête de la saucisse ou d'apartés sur le
terrain mais je pense que si les
énarques et des gens appelés à diriger
le pays avec 200 ans une obligation de
voir ce que c'était que le secteur privé
et pas uniquement chirac
voilà ça ne peut pas dire que chirac il
est très sympathique on parle là bien
exonéré l'ena il est il des retraites
auquel chirac c'était 12 ans
d'immobilisme et 12 ans de retard pour
la faune est ce que quand elle est là
c'est le petit bout de la lorgnette
parce que là c'est d'entreprise et aux
ministres comme ça ça pas été forcément
non car d'énarques qui en réalité sont
dans le privé c'est la vérité je voulais
cela vous ne revoient pas leur en
politique il n' a été créée par de
bréhan roues d'un train dans les années
60 il y à un état qui est extrêmement
fort dans cette dans ces années là
aujourd'hui papa dire que la place de
l'état soit central dans la vie d'une
société c'est peut-être ça aussi la la
la fin de l'ena non je ne suis pas sûr
que l'état ait perdu de son apanage
alors on en parle mieux en termes
d'appareils on avoir de l'état qui était
qui a quant à lui 60 vous deviez faire
des départements veut par exemple sur la
de france va faire des parts aux métiers
d'ouvriers y laissa par babar personnes
discuter c'était la volonté de l'état le
fait du prince
la volonté de l'état et l'application de
ça aujourd'hui vous voyez bien que si
vous voulez prendre une décision vous
avez beau être à voir l'état avec vous
c'est quand même moins facile alors je
suis d'accord avec les 80 km/heure en
délire
mais la méthode je suis d'accord mais
sur l'importance de la peinture tant que
nation convoyer hubbard à mon avis on a
autant besoin qu'on en a eu en 45
aujourd'hui parce qu'on se rend pas
compte de la firme il hier que c'est en
termes d'administration centrale
l'administration déconcentrée
l'administration décentralisée et sans
lieutenant justement alors il y en a
sûrement trop mais sans une politique de
rationalisation
on n'arrivera pas à faire beaucoup donc
je suis pas sûr qu'on ait perdu du poids
en terme de deux machines
je suis d'accord c'est ce que critique
et maquereau est ce qu'il avait annoncé
dès qu'il avait été dès qu'il a été élu
président l'a dit nous ferons un audit
tous les ans les directeurs
d'administration et les directeurs de
haute direction parce qu'on ne peut pas
gouverner un pays à avoir des ministres
qui sont sans arrêt opposé à une
direction qui va l'équivalent des noms
je pense que là dessus il oublié de le
faire parce que de jus mais c'est n'est
pour dire que l'état encore sa place et
les grands corps de l'état sont encore
très importants il est important mais si
vous prenez votre foi afin que les
élèves les plus brillants au un jour
normal sup et l'ena et est aujourd'hui
plus sûre qu'elles vont plutôt vers
harvard ils vont plutôt vers d'autres
formations que l'énarque parce que gérer
l'état c'est quand même moins
ban dont 6 e position que c'est l'été il
ya quelques azim oui mais après c'est un
choix personnel on peut préférer gagné
70 mille euros par mois les mauvais mois
que des villes comme directeur
administration
mais voilà est-ce que ce qu'on a le goût
de l'état ce qu'on a le goût de servir
son pays où est ce qu'on a le goût du
lucre et de secours plaisir personnel va
c'est un sûr mais ça reste peut-être
dans cette tendance d'individualisme
je suis pas sûr que l'ena soit boudée
par rapport à ça puisque je pense que
c'est aujourd'hui perçue comme une était
comme une école managériale et elle mène
beaucoup plus souvent au privé que
public
à mon avis il met il la tue sur le je
suis d'accord que aujourd'hui les
personnes sont plus ancrées à travailler
dans le privé par rapport à eux de voir
l'aspect financier que le travail dans
le public
après je pense que aujourd'hui on peut
quand même travailler en public sans
passer par les dents et bien sûr
l'attendait l'énervé une minorité des
défauts vieux voilà ce que commencer
dans le privé après que dans le public
il ya pas d excuse moi ça serait il
pourrait falloir plus de passerelles il
ya des passerelles du public vers le
trim et des privés république 7% ce qui
est envisagé dans cette nouvelle réforme
je sais qu'il avait proposé une
quatrième voie d'entrée notamment dans
cette nouvelle école qui serait d
réservée aux titulaires de doctorat dans
toutes les sciences humaines
est ce qu'ils ont pensé à une passerelle
avec le privé je suis pas sûr mais
néanmoins avec cette nouvelle méthode de
la gouvernance qui vous le dit est un
peu voilà un petit peu proche des
réalités du privé on pourrait beaucoup
plus envisager ce parallèle qu
auparavant
c'est ce qu'est ce qui fait par exemple
que vous vous avez choisi plutôt lancer
une banque vous aurez pu faire les
identifier oui j'aurais pu et je peux
encore puisque avec ces nouvelles voix
peut-être que je serai amené un haut
responsable du butin
le mot pour l'université j'ai vraiment
aimé ma spécialité haut depuis la
première année j'ai toujours voulu être
constitutionnaliste son fils très
heureuse aujourd'hui dans ma fonction
actuelle
le disque est ce qu'il ya pas ce qu'on
dit souvent qu'il ya une note aux
sélections entre enfin c'est vrai qu'il
ya un annuaire des anciens énorme et
c'est le côté très club finalité est une
formation qui fait qu'on pense d'une
certaine façon ça en gros mais c'est
aussi vrai pour les enseignants
d'université non nous avons nos petits
clubs et les héros du soir
mais bon je crois qu'il ya plus de
diversité vous dirai dans l'enseignement
que chez des énarques direct
l'université est assez individualiste et
de carnet d adresse autant que mais ça
n'est pas uniquement reproche qu'on peut
faire à l'ena à sciences po dans les
grandes écoles à polytech à l'ol n'est
ce finalement ils restent souvent entre
eux d'associations des anciens c'est il
ya des universités alors on essaye
maintenant de les mettre en place mais
enfin bon on peut pas dire que ça crée
des réseaux particulièrement puissant et
je crois que c'est peut-être un petit
peu le problème de ces écoles c'est pas
ton la formation et pas dans les
débouchés c'est la manière dont ensuite
on reste entre soi qui est gênante
clause mercadal et les 90 kilomètres à
l'heure c'est fini la hache non c'est
pas fini c'est juste que l'état dit au
département maintenant vous faites comme
vous voulez c'est vous qui décidez
qu'elle refera 80 quel rôle sera à 90
est je pense une sacrée responsabilité
quand même pour le département parce que
c'est une question de vie j'entendais ce
matin radio quelqu'un du département
jeudi plus qu'un département bref qui
disait que du temps où il y avait 90 il
avait eu quatre morts et l'année
dernière avec 80 ils en ont eu 12 mai
que voilà sont des accidents qui sont
pas forcément liés à la vitesse et l'avs
est liée à autre chose quoi donc 80 90
mais il ne sait pas s'il ya eu une étude
d'impact c'est contradictoire vraie et
très contestée en tout cas va le
réclamer
mais il ya quand même eu ce sentiment
peut-être dans les jets les jo dans le
mouvement des jeunes soit arrêter
d'emmerder les français enfin vie et je
veux dire un type comme colons qui était
quêter connaissait quand même peut-être
qu'on peut reprocher au cs gouvernement
d'être des gens que vous disiez que pas
fait grand chose d'autre que des études
et de la politique des gens qui vivaient
sur le terrain comme collomb avait dit
m'attendais arrêter avec ça fait pas les
80 heures c'est une et ça a été un
déclencheur quand même c'est incroyable
parce que c'est quand même une question
de protection de la sas arriver là où
l'autre la morale et la politique et la
politique c'est compliqué on le voit
aussi sur l'écologie française nationale
sachant pense que la politique de
l'expérimentation justement c'est une
bonne manière de s'en sortir seul
ouais ça marchait pour le rsa c'est un
marché pour les salles de shoot à paris
c'est dire que quand on essaye dans un
dans un petit vivier un petit peu voir
ce qui marche avant de nationaliser au
moins ça permet d'avoir un besoin de
crash test en fait en quelque sorte qui
peut plus faire ce test
voilà un crash est qui a un peu craqué
le premier recul
80 et là ça donne quand même une ima fin
une image pas terrible on décide en
s'arc boutent là dessus on a tord ou à
raison on a pris une décision et le
compte du bon allez on laisse tomber mon
avis une valeur qui est mort entre deux
femmes et de tous les antivirus delon
festival de cannes donc de long va
recevoir une palme d'honneur pour pour
toute sa carrière cinématographique et
on voit notamment aux états unis
bad et des contestations dit comment
vous pouvez remettre une palme d'honneur
à quelqu'un qui est antisémite homophobe
pétition pétition je suis regarde très
peu
vingt mille mains d'un millier de
signatures c'est pas énorme a à peu près
autant qu'elle gilet jaune qui défiera
samedi passé anecdotique non après tous
fait un portrait qui est pas très sympa
l'annoncé pêche n'avait pas donné ce
moment qu'ils veulent faire pardon c'est
comme la photo qu'on voit on en replante
choisir ou safari
il ya quatre des photos du loup jerry
photos plus sympa vu nantes en lacets
non non non on réagira quelqu'un qui
n'aime pas que l'on sait c'est une photo
récente
non mais ce qui est ce qu on peut
distinguer une fois pour toutes belles
une carrière d'acteur et puis des
paroles privé qui on peut compter
est-ce que comme espace condé d'idées
parfois des conneries ça j'aurai tout
dit le débat sera clos
je veux dire on est tous d'accord pour
reconnaître que céline est un des plus
grands romanciers français et je veux
dire tout le monde est d'accord
dax un bon voilà point final
j'adore ces bouquins je ne leur ai même
pas voulu passer une demi seconde avec
cette crapule
avec ce 6e tibi monde dont alain delon
il peut avoir effectivement peut-être un
côté parce que disait lucette qui était
pourtant avec lui c'est ce qu'elle dit
toujours dit joël des gens vivants c'est
incroyable de ces la femme de ses idées
voilà donc après que deux que delon et
des défauts sur moi ça ça reste un
comédien extraordinaire il a voté
quelque chose de thenon oui j'ai
tellement de monde
je pense le trophée il on va dire que le
mythe puisque ont fait le parallèle
entre sa vie fut et et ça ça lui
prouvait sa carrière c'est exceptionnel
apparemment est exceptionnel donc le
trophée récompense à sa carrière et non
pas sa vie privée donc oui mais
quelqu'un qui a joué monsieur klein dire
qu'il est antisémite
ça ferait cette tendance du festival de
cannes de vouloir être du côté des
démunis du côté des fans du côté des
minorités laissez nous un peu de
paillettes et un peu de glamour dans la
besoin eh ben c'est sur ces paroles que
nous avons dû quitter merci à tous les 4
et 7 passes et fini très vite pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]